of attention but what what you're
calling the five
a certain man might not call a five he
might call you eight or two mm-hmm so i
think no
but there's general standards there is i
do feel like there's more motivation
needed to improve yourself as a woman
well for myself i've struggled with my
weight so i know that the motivation i
put into my business for example i
haven't put it into myself in the same
way
but i know that because my business is
thriving the same energy i put into that
i can use it and apply it into my weight
but i feel like there's some there's a
lot of women out there who maybe they
don't have the mental capacity because
they haven't achieved anything or they
haven't successfully done something for
themselves so that there's that lack of
motivation to even look at themselves
yeah i think it's down to the fact that
men um women are born of value whilst
men have to create their value
so even as a woman you can just walk out
there on the street someone's gonna
cater to you in some way shape or form
as a man before you even get awarded a
seat at the sexual marketplace table you
need to become something you need to be
worth something
if you're lucky enough to be born good
looking young then that's your entrance
but for most men that's not the case for
most women you can be but ugly as long
as you've got a ton tone someone's going
to try and stick it somewhere so i think
that's the fundamental difference you
have to acknowledge that you're born of
value whilst we have to create do you
think if you couldn't get a relationship
that you would lose weight quicker if
you got no attention from men in the
world
i probably wouldn't be overweight i
think i've i've always said my problem
is i still get attention yeah
and now the attention is even different
because
you know the the body shape i have looks
like the body shape that women are
paying for
so for me it's annoying because even
though i shouldn't really compare myself
to people i'm annoyed i'm like i just
wish i i hated myself enough to change
wouldn't you say in a way that work
that's men bailing out women for bad
decisions in a way
yeah because yeah yeah probably not
something girl's gonna say i've had this
conversation with men where they're like
i don't care like they've been on dates
they don't actually ask the girl what
she does because they don't care they
don't care yeah so i was gonna say so is
it it's like a shoe collection so so
could you say that like they not that
they don't want us to improve but let's
say she works in mcdonald's you not
don't actually require
sometimes you don't require
much edification well yeah but they want
us to look hot yeah so they might and
they might want us to be less
argumentative just improve in certain
aspects but maybe not in
feminine friendly submissive and it
depends on the quality of guy you're
going for the problem is that the
market's always good because there's
such a small fraction of when you're
actually worth something in society so
the men who aren't worth something are
the ones that are going to be like you
know what if she gives it up
their hyenas is ready to pounce so i
think that's part of the problem
it's funny i remember having that same
thought because i lost a bunch of weight
like a couple years ago and i remember
having the same thought like when i got
past a certain weight that you still get
like attention but for me it just wasn't
like the attention i wanted
yeah i mean i've i've been all sorts of
sizes
um and i do notice the attention is
different when i'm smaller
i was also younger as well but um
people do treat you differently mentally
i mean at this way i attract a certain
man i know the man if i know where to go
i know the kind of man i'll get but i
think when i was smaller
there was a there was a variety of men
it was all races
all cultures all colors why are you able
to have this conversation and because a
lot of overweight women like get very
mad when they hear my show because i
think it's something i'm working on so
like i'm trying to lose weight i'm
actually doing stuff you know yeah okay
no that's cool um
who wants do you think
would you rate yourselves one to ten
myself a six
six
i would say i've watched kevin samuels i
would say an adjustable six if i was
gonna say that
[Laughter]
you don't wanna get slated
i think i'm a four and a half okay
i think
when i say when i say i have a
conversation with my wife quite often
but when i say a number i feel like now
nowadays i feel like i'm disrespected
when i say this number but i generally
think i'm like a six but she digs
well you're married i'll give you a hand
number for the fact that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we just want to look at this
yeah
my number changed based on what they
said as well it did affect what because
i'm not going to rate myself higher than
women who are younger than me i'm just
not going to do it
because i know i know how it is
okay what about you me
i honestly think i'm a six i think my
personality does it for me stuff me too
i'm not gonna lie and that's fine right
that's why it's okay i grew up ugly wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait when do you write them
slower do you feel like a woman's
personality could make you like her like
could she she might she might be a fool
but her personality could make you wise
to be a certain level of attractive for
your personality to take you over i
reckon i i honestly believe i'd rather
wife a girl he was less attractive by
the greater personality
i don't want because i think the more
attractive a girl is the more crazy she
is because there's no one and no one's
ever held her accountable she wanted the
the prop the best girl to get is a girl
that was ugly in school who blossomed
into her beauty because she had to learn
to navigate the
learn about men by being around men
because you never got men and then now
you get men
if your mind is in in the right place
then that's that's the sweet you know
what's so crazy i grieve him so much
because i was a tomboy and i think i was
quite
well i'm dark skinned so in school back
in the day was like oh you're dark
you're blick so i remember at the day i
consciously said i want to become a
tomboy i said so no man can tell me if
i'm pretty i'm not pretty and and then i
just became mandem i just became one of
the boys and you see that key of
navigating around the ways it is so i
think it's very true
why do you think it's okay in society
for
us to say men are trash but it's not
okay for men to say women are horrors
even though it's more true i think they
can
okay
do you think on a public platform if
yeah you have a podcast if you went on
your podcast and just said modern women
are [ __ ]
wait but is that a generalization
but but women but women generalize all
the time they say they're afraid to walk
alone at night
i think i i think women call themselves
[ __ ] in different ways so they call
himself sugar babies they call himself
but we're not talking about the women
i'm saying like why is that okay in
society
because it means that you have to accept
that the opposite sex and acknowledges
your flaw and they acknowledge that you
are a [ __ ] that's what it is
no women are sensitive
i think you know when another woman you
know as a joke you say oh you're a bee
or you know you're a [ __ ] yeah they say
like oh it's candy it's cute and candied
but when a man says it's you you know
like when a guy says to you you don't
look good in those clothes you know he
means that he's not gonna say he's not
gonna say like just to be horrible if
he's telling you oh darling you're a
[ __ ] he means who means you know what
it is you've kind of been caught because
sometimes i feel like girls will be like
i've done the same friendship group it
means your whole when a man has to open
his mouth and say honestly for him
because you know men don't care about
stuff men those men only talk when they
need to you're [ __ ] babes i think a
woman a woman's got to maintain a social
capital
so a man being able to call her a [ __ ]
just diminishes the social capital
because
that's that's who you you're of value to
you're not of value to other girls
you're value to men so especially if the
guy is the guy that you like if you see
an attractive guy call you a horse game
it's game over
what do you think no i agree honestly
because if a guy came up to me and said
i'm a [ __ ] i would just
i've just